wilson net marin
the team sees it by google launches
and today's episode let's see how
add action bar in your application
android and tuning what is chumbar is a
navigation pattern that will allow
in all the screens you have a space
reserved to show the user and items
navigation and also some identity
your application, but because
had to use in-app crash
android
the first thing because the
most used navigation from your
appearance on android 3.0 also because
becomes a dedicated space to give a
your app's visual identity and
also indicate to the user where it
is that exact moment
we have to think he's going to
important actions of your team and
thus allowing them to be accessed
intuitively 50 you think a lot
He will find what he has to do.
screen and also clear how we spoke
that it is well used with parents
navigation and will offer support
consistent with its epe and in relation
operational system
so the sun is already accustomed to seeing
this type of navigation pattern in the
wet now then a classic example
of the action bar was here in the
to the air navigation reserved for
from navigation and we have on the right
the actions that your application will take
for each screen you can also have
some actions on the bottom that the
split action bar case do not fit on top
or has a smaller screen that is like some
previously used versions of gmail
Let's have a look at the left part.
where are you seeing here this minor
I think this is the smallest he can
to be empty in the truth that
mainly in the home or the screen
application, it may have
this sign of less than in Argentina the
diap navigation that when you are taken
by a hierarchically superior screen
until August at the moment example a screen
details with a list screen
for example and then we have here
these three lists where it is to indicate the
droid layout that drawer
that boy who comes from the left to
and has been used by many
android apps
well then we have the icon that is one thing
you have to pay close attention to your
application that is a detail that is the
visual identity of your application
can bennett explore a boat then
try to avoid this, people are not
cool to have an empty part he's in
white in your action will then try
avoid this is normal the default is the
use icon
since you have invested heavily in your
icon is identity duty only goes
understand where you are in your app and
you also have the option of using the logo
if you have a logo that has the name
application, or what gives you the most
speed for you as the case of the
youtube also you can use
just do not forget that soon to be a little
the bigger one ends up taking up a little space
in the navigation part
then I'll close pages linking us
We have the part where you will choose
some way some other form of
Navigation, come on, have a look.
so bet on an isp ner that
As you click on it, you can
choose from multiple views such as
example the google plan can only choose
the circles
I can have a title the screen title
the application name is something that
Identify is that moment I can have
the tags also that we will see this
in another episode where you will power
organize your app's tags and
also last but not least
supports in the layout itself as per
example black clouds on google drive
that give the notion to the user in which folder
from google drive
he is in that good moment we go
pass a share of actions here I have
here are some icons that we call
action items in this case I can
use an icon
the context icon or just the text you
You have to choose which one looks better on your
application is reminding
I upload the minute as I click it there
can give an option of other actions
that item you clicked
or even if you press and
a tip that he who suddenly makes a
specific training icon that is not
so intuitive of canton has left
impress and see if you have any tips
After that you can also have some
elements that it
formed when they are actuated here is
seeing the refresh case when she asks
to upgrade and becomes an icon
animated to indicate the user is
some action or even some
actions where I click on the search case is
very common and he already had
right in the box to search without
need to go to another screen, right?
so you already have to save space
in its trunk and also here in part of the
boss would check where we are here
asking boss actions can use
this option and when it clicks it opened - in
there of the share options that have
available to the user all this
talking about actions in action a bar
then we have to finally the menu
or overflow boy is that we
people in some articles that talk about
goodbye that menu key that many
We do not even have the
menu physics so it will have there actions
which are not so frequent and common
your application and this case shows well
For example, there are chaos 70
settings or help
are themes like time is no longer
entering but it has an easy way to
find this screen there
now that you already know what it is
steal and its main features
let's see how to add it application
android just a note that we are going
consider the use of the
remembers that you can then use
action on by in previous applications to
version 3
Okay, so I had to create a
class that extends from action activity
then you will use or extend one of the
themes
tm point is that shares plaza tivit tem
up to an example of how you will use
this theme in your optics and there
by default the system will use the
icon of your app as a reference
from chumbar
if you want to use me the logo when
We were explaining it now.
you will have to use the attribute
logo or application or on active
yes action on will use the logo
instead of the icon a look in the code
to see in practice how this
sequence that I just explained I
I'm watching here I called 20
is extending from action bar tite
remembering the support hare
but besides doing this it has to
set up that I had to use the theme
correct and this will then
that you are here and here in the
android tm
in the case all looking directly at tm
point is shared light
you could use another theme inside
space cinema or estenter create a
theme your little boy then like
is running on the device
I have here so Edson goes demo with
the default icon that did not win, and
and I have here on the left the
if the referendum were to be used
this here is a more basic example
simple to use to hit you
noticed that the bar with a
Bit empty, right?
let's now how to add some
items to your ex a bar
you have to know is that the system will
be a method a client menu options
who will popular his bar with the seven
items
this is done what this method is going to
inflate 11 menu file that will be
in the part of services that goes then
put the action and items in one place
good correspondent we are seeing here a
example of a menu file where
in this case an action sert
It's there we know it's going to go
make an action the item that has the option
and f 2.0 chan is called the action
exactly speaking that this item is a
action item and that is the
compatibility with the
previous android because society
did not exist then let's define this
namespace of your application and there
yes not to have problem with compilation
good xml
after that I have to implement the
method a client menu options tap
screen that shows using the service -
a flyer making the influent of the file
that in the case that I called man
activity actions touch and return the menu
who has been inflated a patient bar goes
set your items
after that you have to treat when the
user clicks on one of the items for this
you will implement the options method
select item that it is called with
drinks selected
you go
Finishing was selected and range
instance of menu item that is passed
as a parameter executing jet method and
There you have it after that you have identified
and you have selected you perform the action
that you want a nomad then in the
implemented method where I make a
switch exactly lisandro ghetti there you are
of the item was passed as parameter and
if it's a 717 case I'll do a search if
for peace action with landing
I do another action here and with this
I'll correctly handle the click on the
action or item
let's look at how it would look in code
this sequence of instructions that people
just show I have to first
the client options menu where I will do the
influence of the menu file and in
case or activity actions that will have
so the items looking here in this
file I have in the case two items o
first seven years that will never be
displayed with the action the item so that
the show as action as never like me
I spoke about situations that are not constant and
your application
search action and put as show
Edson Alves or is always going to be
present in the action father then with you
then put the user click here
in our tivit I have argument
options item select that receives the same
item and then I do that is a point item
get the through a switch and in the case and
I checked the option that was you were from
7 or if it was 7 months and then take action
according to what the eyes selected
With that, you guys can already
use action multiple action items in
your android app in the next
videos we will present some
additional resources to further improve
more the user experience on your
application we will see the next debates